ces génies en fait ça marche tous les
jours de la semaine un joli il ya
toujours des génies et on attaque avec
du haut de gamme avec la bataille des
coupes sur tf6
j'ai une bonne nouvelle benjamin castadi
réunit désormais toutes les conditions
pour participer
on prend que chacun thing de la bataille
des couples il adore la chirurgie
esthétique
il connaît très bien les problèmes de
couple il a la même passion que le
candidat qui s'appelle maxime ça
s'appelle un tiercé dans l'ordre c'est
pour vous regarder le soleil chaises
musicales 1 2 3 soleil retour en enfance
[Musique]
hipay décontraction
yu
j'ai voulu regarder bizarrement non avec
compassion en fait
ah oui c'est vrai bah oui vous avez une
recette vous en tant que médecin pour
éviter ces légendes je ne pète pas tout
l'art était arrêté quand on fait une
fois par émission ce n'est pas une
légende ce une réalité
oui madame oui mais c'est très
certainement lié à son alimentation il
doit il s'alimente très mal et puis
s'alimente par les yeux une habitude
avec le crous villa de fuji il passe des
heures à peaufiner leur stratégie pour
gagner le jeu et cette fois ci ils ont
mis au point la stratégie du switch en
se basant sur l'air et les couleurs des
équipes
alors je vous le dis vous vous demandez
tous ici qu'est ce que c'est que cette
stratégie eh bien je pense qu'après leur
explication
vous allez encore plus vous le demander
regardez on est sur une vraie partie
d'échecs
en cas de succès à des scripts ses 120
ans du démoli
c'est le rose et le violet on va faire
suite chez les gris et les lyonnais pour
que les roses et les cris soient nominés
on aura tous à voter en votre accomplir
aux écrits que les genêts et les crises
et les rose et le violet c'est simple
[Musique]
j'avais alors qu'ils n'ont pas de
l'amour ils ont la même passion les
conneries ce sont les marseillais w9
alors dans la famille des marseillais je
le représente
greg craig il est beau il est drôle il
est tatoué mais il a un langage très
particulier puisqu'il parle uniquement
en recettes de cuisine regarder en 3
insultes le mec il vous propose un
brunch elle malgré elle m'a montré rôle
que c'était une grosse merguez je sens
venir nous parle
pensez que j'ai tendu vers lesquels en
fait est là elle tire sur guirado
toute ma vie je me fais reprendre les
gens moment communaux me lève d'un impôt
plat tu va empoisonner des gens quoi
ça c'est une vraie stratégie de leur
part parce que les vrais insultes sont
automatiquement billets parce que c'est
des équipes expérimentées
donc pour que ça passe et pour que ça
reste d'arcade en le moment il utilise
comme ça des métallos l'émission devrait
faire ça genre cornichons mais voilà
tout ça pas mal on va le faire
maintenant ça est très bonne à bravo bah
oui c'est prouvé trucs intéressants
qu'on est dit dans l'émission la filière